What if your car opened the doors not with a key but by scanning your face?
That's just one example of new technology Toyota is working on now.
It's part of a new partnership with Microsoft.
A new group called Toyota Connected...
...will focus on technology for tomorrow's vehicles.
Say your hands are full with groceries or you're carrying luggage,...
...the car's rear camera will scan your face, see that your hands are full...
...and pop open the back hatch automatically.
Let's just hope you don't have an evil twin that wants to borrow your car.
The team is also looking at new ways to gather data on drivers...
...with vehicles that report on hazards in the road ahead,...
...and then that info can help warn other drivers on the same road...
...or offer immediate rerouting.